Jason Bateman please do more serious
roles you're good at it
disconnect is a film that I saw recently
and I had not seen a trailer for this
movie and I didn't read a plot synopsis
for the film I could just tell that it
had something to do with the way
electronic media can control people's
lives or affect them it's about a group
of people and you have these
interconnecting stories that at some
points converge at some points don't but
each one of these characters is strongly
affected by electronics the media social
networking the internet the news and
it's a way that all of these things
combine to show how it can seriously
harm a person's life and some of my
friends who saw it with me likened it to
crash I would say that's a fair
comparison but it seems a little bit
more smaller-scale and what I mean by
that is that it's a film that shows
things that some people in the world may
view as innocent or just simply harmless
and it exposes those things for just how
dangerous they actually can be this film
has a very good cast you have Jason
Bateman in there as a father who's
dealing with a tragic event in his life
there's another story with Paula Patton
and Alexander Skarsgard as a couple
affected by internet identity theft
there's a story about the media and news
reporting and how that can affect
people's lives dangerously and possibly
the most effective story in the film
that kind of feels like it's the central
one that gets the most attention because
it actually is the best one in my
opinion is this one about how bullying
through the internet can truly affect
someone's life and then that person's
family's life disconnect is a really
really well made film with terrific
performances this is the kind of movie
that you can't go into expecting oh this
is just gonna be a nice little fun
experience where I watch these inter
connecting stories and they'll go home
and they'll be so happy about it now
this is a really deeply affecting movie
and it gets pretty personal at times and
there are times in this movie where you
are going to be very disturbed because
it's a film that is very realistic in
one sense see this isn't the kind of
movie that shows everyone who types
their texts through Facebook and their
phone has exactly perfect grammar and
punctuation no they show like the
mistakes that people generally make I
really like that how they actually
showed everything very authentic when
they show a Facebook page in this movie
it looks like a Facebook page there
isn't some fake social networking
website that looks like Facebook but it
has a different name like
head book or something I make a lot of
money if I made that website that's a
bad idea but this film tries very hard
to be just totally authentic and for
that reason there are times when this
movie feels really white-hot with drama
and I really really like that about this
film the performances in this movie are
great as I said in my intro Jason
Bateman is an actor who generally does
comedy he's been in serious roles before
like state of play with Russell Crowe
and Rachel McAdams but here he gives
performance that I've never seen him
give this is the best performance I've
ever seen Jason Bateman give ever for
the first half or so of the movie he
kind of his in and out of the frames and
he doesn't really have that much to do
but it's really the second half of the
film with his character just kind of
explodes and I thought he did such a
good job in this movie and I'd love to
see him do more serious roles like this
Paula Patton and Alexander Skarsgard did
a really good job in the film Michael
Nyqvist I can never get that guy's last
paint but he's from the original Girl
with the Dragon Tattoo and Mission
Impossible Ghost Protocol along with
Paula Patton that's interesting they
were both in that movie connections
that's how my brain works when I think
of two actors that are in the same movie
and I realize oh they're in that movie
then my brain is like exploding with
ideas and I have to control it but this
movie is important for people to see I
really think it is especially young
people because there's a new generation
of kids nowadays and even some adults
who have taken on this persona where
they feel like they can become a
different person on the Internet and
they have absolutely no idea
you know the harm that that can actually
cause and sometimes people feel like
well if I'm on the internet and I can
type whatever I want or say whatever I
want it doesn't really matter and this
film really opens up the doors to show
the consequences of those actions not
just on the person that they're
attacking but on the online attackers
there is serious consequences in this
film that are realistic and have
happened in real life and I really like
the fact that the film did not hold back
from showing these things and I really
really commend the filmmakers for that
this isn't a movie that ends with a
whole bunch of literal explosions and
car chases and everything this is a film
where a whole bunch of characters
interlocking interweave in certain ways
that becomes very riveting in its final
10 to 15 minutes the only issues that I
had with this film are that it is a
little slow paced
it's a little bit longer than it should
have been and whenever you have a film
with multiple stories there's always
going to be that one story that's just
not as interesting as others and then
one other story that will rise to the
top and then you'll go back to that one
other story and you really okay here's
the one that's just kind of alright
let's get to the next one because that
one is the one that I'm really focused
on the most and that's really the
biggest flaw of these types of films
whenever you have multiple stories
interweaving like this there's always
that one that just isn't quite as good
as the rest but overall I would
definitely recommend seeing disconnect
it's not a big huge movie that it's none
of people are going to go out and see
but I do think it is an important film
but it's one of those films that just
does not hold back from some of the
horrible things that happen in society
nowadays based off of the Internet in
the news and electronic media I'm gonna
give disconnect a B+ so if you guys have
seen the film I'd like to know what you
thought of it or if you've had an
experience of some kind in which your
life has been affected adversely by the
internet or by the news or by any form
of electronic media or social networking
tell your story below that'd be
interesting to hear that as well if you
can maybe get a little discussion going
a support group on the disconnect movie
review by Chris document as always guys
thanks a lot for watching and if you
liked this review you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes